bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission que même ta mère regarde
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la soviétisation de l'économie
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches
assistons à une soviétisation de
l'économie c'est la question qui va nous
occuper tout au long de cette émission
on tentera à d'abord d'expliquer à quoi
correspond ce terme
et puis on verra dans quelle mesure il
peut s'appliquer à la façon dont nos
économies évoluent pour en parler en
deuxième partie nous serons en liaison
avec philippe crevel économiste et
directeur du cercle de l'epagne olivier
on va tout de suite rentré dans le vif
du sujet quand on part soviétisation de
l'économie de quoi parle-t-on
éléments de réponse avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine d'assas la soviétisation de
l'économie c'est une thèse selon
laquelle nos économies occidentales
seraient en train de glisser de plus en
plus vers un modèle proche de celui de
l'urss disparue en 91
l'état y avait un rôle dominant sur
l'économie une place prépondérante du
public par rapport au privé qui était
sinon inexistants sous contrôle
gouvernemental
de même pour la planification économique
c'est l'état soviétique qui fixait les
objectifs de production si le
capitalisme a toujours régné en maître
sur l'occident depuis la crise sanitaire
il est vrai que l'état a pris une autre
dimension au sein de nos économies
prenant en charge des salaires via le
chômage partiel en france
versant des aides aux entreprises sans
regarder à la dépense en somme
assurer la survie de l'économie via une
perfusion d'argent frais même pour la
planification chez nous c'est françois
bayrou qui mène la barque en tant que
haut commissaire au plan
en mars le ministre des comptes publics
en france évalué la facture globale des
aides à 160 milliards d'euros soit 7% du
pib français aux états unis biden lui
à débloquer 1900 milliards allant
jusqu'à envoyer des chèques dans les
boîtes aux lettres des américains cette
idée de soviétisation de l'économie
n'est d'ailleurs pas nouvelle en 2018
bien avant la crise un article du
journal libéral contrepoint évoqué déjà
cette métamorphose et s'amuser à
comparer la place des politiques
publiques de l'urss de 1953 et celle de
la france de 2010 est il dressait déjà
des points communs à l'époque à travers
certains chiffres mais constater tout de
même que le privé l'emporté largement
sur le public
aujourd'hui après la réapparition de
l'état providence pour faire face à la
crise nous le doute que la frontière
entre d2 est devenu beaucoup plus ténu
voilà pour les explications du tiroir
cash olivier est d'abord est ce que
cette définition de soviétisation
l'économie vous convient et est on en
train de glisser vers ce concept doit
écouter je vous en parle depuis
longtemps de la soviétisation de
l'économie alors qu'en jeu quand j'ai
commencé à en parler tout le monde me
regarder bizarrement ai pensé que
c'était parce que je travaillais sur rt
que cette idée saugrenue mais tu es venu
mais pas du tout c'est c'est simplement
une place de plus en plus prépondérante
de l'état que ce soit dans la la
nationalisation si vous voulez des
moyens de production et que ce soit
aussi directement la part de 2 des
revenus qui viennent de l'état pour les
ménages rendez vous compte que aux états
unis on en est aujourd'hui à plus d'un
tiers des revenus moyens des américains
qui vient de l'état sous différentes
formes axes soit l'échec de baden avant
l'échec trump que ce soit les les
indemnisations chômage que ce soit tout
ça tout cumulé vous avez plus vous avez
34 % des revenus des ménages américains
qui viennent de l'état donc les doigts
olivier
et 34% c c'est la fête de saint louis
qui a sorti cette salle est ici pas très
compliqué à calculer donc vous avez ce
cette montée en puissance si vous voulez
de l'état qui est on est en train
d'assister on entend parler beaucoup du
revenu universel et que c'était donc
vous êtes dans quelque chose où vous
allez finir par toucher des chèques
directement de l'état
ça sera votre salaire et avec une
nationalisation des moyens de production
tout simplement parce que aujourd'hui
avec les prêts garantis par l'état et
c'est fait
l'état se paye les entreprises donc donc
on est dans quelque chose qui ressemble
à une soviétisation alors maintenant on
n'est pas peut-être au point de l'union
soviétique des années 50-60 mais ça
n'empêche qu'on s'y dirige tout droit et
que visiblement dans les propositions
que font certains sur les propositions
économiques que font certains on voit
bien qu'il ya quand même une trajectoire
qui va dans ce sens là donc ça pourrait
drôle que finalement la russie devienne
ur est le dernier pays capitalistes au
monde ça pourrait être amusant c'est
d'un drôle de retour de bâton merci tout
de suite la deuxième partie de cette
émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec philippe crevel bonjour monsieur
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous êtes économiste et directeur du
cercle de l'epargne bienvenus bonjour
alors philippe crevel pour commencer qu
est ce que vous vous entendez par
soviétisation avec l'économie et est-ce
qu'on peut dire que l'on est
actuellement dans une soviétisation de
l'économie la soviétisation de
l'économie ce sont deux éléments à
prendre en compte
premièrement c'est la possession du
capital productif par l'état donc son
temps de l'urss au temps des démocraties
populaires en europe de l'est c'était
l'état qui possédait la majorité on va
dire du capital des entreprises
il y avait un secteur privé mais qui
était extrêmement marginale
ce n'est pas le cas encore aujourd'hui
en occident
même si comme l'a souligné olivier avec
des prêts garantis par l'état peut-être
que donc l'état pourrait devenir un
partenaire un actionnaire douteraient à
d'un très grand nombre d'entreprises
françaises
mais ce serait pas la possession total
du capital qui aujourd'hui à partir au
privé pardon de vous couper pour autant
aujourd'hui l'état c'est le deuxième
actionnaire du cac 40
c'est en france il ya toujours eu une
présence importante de l'état
il ya eu quand même une vague de
privatisations qui a été engagée à
partir de 1986 qui a fait réduire le
poids de l'état en france de manière
très importante
la dernière grande vague de
nationalisations c'était en 1980 avec
les groupes industriels les principaux
groupes industriels les banques les
assurances on est loin on va dire du
point maximal de l'état en france
depuis donc
une bonne vingtaine d'années l'autre
point qu'il faut prendre en compte pour
la civilisation c'est la planification
au temps de l'urss s'était l'état
central qui décident est qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait produire
comment il fallait produire et qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait consommer on reste
aujourd'hui dans une économie de marché
où ce sont les acteurs économiques qui
décident ce qu'ils vont faire ou pas
faire donc
certes on voit bien et je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit olivier c'est que il ya
aujourd'hui une situation très
particulière qui fait que l'état monte
en puissance à la demande des citoyens
qui veulent de plus en plus de
protection et qu'on se rapproche d'un
système mixte c'est vrai que par rapport
à une situation privée qu'on pouvait
connaître surtout aux états-unis au
royaume-uni en france a toujours été
favorable à l'économie
nationaliser donc pourvu des deux
éléments que vous avez cités pour qui
conditionne la soviétisation de
l'économie aujourd'hui on peut on parle
de quoi on parle plus
d'interventionnisme un peu plus marquée
qu'avant je parlerai beaucoup je
parlerai beaucoup plus
d'interventionnisme on est un peu dans
une logique d'économie de guerre où
l'état a suppléé on va dire à la
défaillance du privé parce que le privé
ne pouvait pas produire et que l'état
fournit des revenus de manière donc
conséquente c'est vrai qu'avant la crise
sanitaire l'état fournissait déjà on va
dire un tiers donc 2 des revenus en
france aussi on a cité les états unis
mais les dépenses sociales en france les
prestations sociales c'est un tiers du
pib pour les personnes les plus modestes
ça peut représenter 50 à 60 70 % de leur
revenu donc de chez les 10% les plus
modestes
et c'était avant la crise donc on est
c'est vrai dans un une logique d'état
assistance qui sait qu'ils étaient
fortes avant la crise et qui s'est
renforcée avec la crise
la question est de savoir est-ce que ce
cette situation va perdurer
où est ce qu'on va revenir à une
situation normale d'ici deux trois
quatre ans donc la question est là est
ce qu'en fait on a pris des habitudes
d'un état ultra présent omniscient qui
fait tout où est ce qu'on va revenir à
une situation on va dire classique donc
on était en et économie de guerre entre
39 et 45
avec l'état faisait tous plus ou moins
bien et après on est revenu à une
situation d' économie de marché
est-ce que là ça va être le cas la
question reste ouverte olivier vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire à philippe crevel pas forcément
parce que comparer ça à l'économie
guerre dans dans les guerres il ya des
destructions et c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on évite aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
l'état aujourd'hui aide tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est bien le problème
c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas cette
fameuse destruction créatrice qui fait
que aujourd'hui on entretient des des
zombies j'en reparle mais dont on
entretient des zombies qui met une
pression sur les sociétés qui elles ne
le sont pas qui ont qui met une pression
déflationniste sur parce que des
capacités de production qui sont bien
trop élevés qui sont qui ne sont pas
bénéficiaires
donc l'état a tout fait pour conserver
tout ça en substituant du chiffre
d'affaires par de la dette ce qui est
une aberration et donc on voit et dans
l'est dans les différentes dans les
différentes réactions des politiques et
indications des politiques on voit
qu'ils utilisent cette ce prétexte du
coc vide pour au contraire à aller de
plus en plus loin dans cette
soviétisation alors moi je veux bien
qu'on l'appelle interventionnisme de
l'état mais c'est plus en plus donc bien
sûr qu'on en ait pas à l'union
soviétique des 12 et 10 des années 50 60
mais on se dirige tout de même vers une
société qui est de plus en plus l'état
intervient de plus en plus quand vous
avez entendu parler récemment 2
du salaire universel on se dit que une
fois que il est mis en place
qu'est ce qui va se passer on va vous
dire là où il faut dépenser l'argent en
plus sinon vous ne donnera pas donc on
est dans une société qui est de plus en
plus avec un état omniscient omnipotent
ni et qui régit vos vite on vous oblige
à vous vacciner parce que sinon vous
pourrez pas prendre l'avion vous pourrez
par vivent normalement on est en train
de se lier teasé malgorn ce qui est
quand même un inquiétant
olivier ce qu'est ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que vous dénoncez une
soviétisation de l'économie pourtant il
ya eu des privatisations a dernièrement
on avait fait d'ailleurs une émission
dessus du coup c'est un petit peu
paradoxal de dénoncer des privatisations
et en même temps une soviétisation parce
que vous privatiser d'une part quelques
sociétés pour donner ces sociétés qui
ont été montés généralement avec des
investissements étatiques c'est à dire
nous finalement qui les avons qui les
avons créé ces sociétés les sociétés
d'autoroutes extra et ensuite on l'est
on les fils à quelques copains dans des
conditions qui sont pas toujours très
claires donc ça n'a rien à voir là
aujourd'hui ce qu'on y fasse là où on
intervient là où on met des prêts
garantis et serra par l'état c'est c'est
le tissu de pme d'artisans etc
c'est évidemment pas les sociétés du
cac40 donc ça n'a rien à voir et c'est
ça qui est eux qui est inquiétant c'est
que aujourd'hui quand vous avez des gens
qui ont accepté des prêts garantis par
l'état mais qui n'ont pas un modèle
économique durable
il va on va faire quoi on va le regarder
leurs prêts garantis par l'état jusqu'à
plus soif
jusqu'aux élections jusqu'à quand donc
on peut pas tout le temps
je vous dis remplacer de l'activité bat
part de la bête c'est ridicule et dette
qui sera potentiellement jamais
rembourser donc qui va soutenir vava va
subir ça c'est nous dans nos impôts si
donc c'est encore une fois ridicule
gd crevel rapidement avant de lancer la
pub une réaction à ce que vient de dire
olivier évidemment bon je n'irai pas
aussi loin qu olivier sur ce sujet un
premièrement je pense que les titres
enfin que les prêts garantis par l'état
au sein des pme
donc vraiment les pme vont rembourser
une grande partie parce qu'elles n'ont
pas consommé ces prêts avait pris ces
prêts pour par sécurité la consommation
ça à peu près aujourd'hui autour de 40%
de près consommer donc les 60 % vont
pouvoir être relativement facilement
donc être remboursés c'est vrai que je
pourrais servir une entreprise qui les
ont utilisées qui ont une rentabilité
qui devait déjà défaillante avant il y
aura certainement des pertes en ligne et
il va falloir que l'état impasse
évidemment ça donc en perte
c'est évident sur la période de
remboursement wii aura un allongement il
y aura peut-être une transformation donc
en fonds propres titres participatifs
l'état se mêlera pas de la gestion des
entreprises sera d'ailleurs confié à des
banques ou la bpi déléguera cette
fonction à des représentants au niveau
régional départemental mais il y aura
pas d'immixtion je pense parce que
l'état n'est pas armée pour le faire et
d'ailleurs perdrait beaucoup de son
temps après c'est vrai je partage la
thèse d'olivier sur ce qu'on appelle les
zombies c'est sûr cela ralentit le
renouvellement du tissu productif en
france cela favorise le maintien
d'entreprises peu rentable mais on va
dire que dans un contexte politique très
chahuté la france a on va dire depuis
une dizaine d'années supporter à la fois
la crise donc de 2008 sur les subprimes
sa crise des dettes souveraines la crise
des gilets jaunes à crise des retraites
et il est vrai que le gouvernement
n'avait aujourd'hui pas d'autre moyen
que de faire le quoi qu'il en coûte pour
essayer de se sauver
et donc c'est une succession on va dire
d'événements qui a amène la france met
d'ailleurs également sur d'autres pays
européens
à cet interventionnisme massif la
question se savoir évidemment si on
retrouve la liberté et si on retrouve
surtout la croissance pour permettre le
remboursement est de retrouver des
conditions normales de fonctionnement
d'économie de marché et on va reparler à
juste après la pub
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire de cette émission
la soviétisation de l'économie et pour
en parler nous sommes en liaison avec
philippe crevel économiste et directeur
du cercle de l'epargne olivier il ya un
il y en qui on l'a compris il ya ce
concept de soviétisation de l'économie
qui revient sur la table et là aussi
encore c'est un petit peu paradoxal et
on le voit d'ailleurs beaucoup sur le
terrain nombreux sont ceux à dénoncer
les casse du service public et une
tendance à privatiser je pense par
exemple à la banque de france
dernièrement alors parlé de
soviétisation de l'économie mais avoue
avoir tout de même un l'opinion publique
qui parle de casse du service public là
aussi c'est encore paradoxal enfin la
casse du service public je vois pas le
je vois pas le rapport avec ce qu'on dit
sur les sur les entreprises privées les
entreprises privées sont aujourd'hui sur
aidé et je vous dis on essaie de en gros
de nationaliser les moyens de production
là la casse du service public
aujourd'hui mais n'a pas la banque de
france est en train de privatiser tout
un secteur leurs activités enfin la
banque de france vous savez on peut se
poser la question de savoir à quoi elle
sert depuis qu'on a la bce 1 la banque
de france c'est un espèce de machin qui
permet de payer des gros salaires à un
certain nombre de gouverneurs et sous
gouverneur de la banque de france qui ne
fichent rien de leur journée donc
excusez moi mais moi ça me chagrine pas
que la banque de france est à être soit
en partie privatisée si vous voulez
c'est pas ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire
si au moins c'est c'est plus nous qui
payons ces salaires à des gens qui je
vous dis faut pas grand-chose ça mais ça
me gêne pas et ça ne ça ne ne vient pas
en contradiction avec ce qu'on vous dit
sur les pme sur les restaurants sur les
activités événementielles sur et serra
qui sont aujourd'hui de fait tellement
aidés que le l'état devient de fait
alors bien sûr qui sera pas actionnaire
de tout c'est de toutes ces entreprises
de toutes ces pme etc
mais vous savez quand quand vous avez à
un niveau d'emprunt qui est très élevé
en fait vous appartenez au banquier ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de même s'il n'est
pas actionnaire vous appartenez de fait
aux banquiers qui vous a prêté de
l'argent et qui peut vous couper les
vivres à tout moment donc toutes vos
décisions sont sont induits par par
votre taux d'endettement qui et qui fait
que vous appartenez à celui qui vous a
prêté de l'argent qu'ils écrivent elles
une réaction à ce que je viens
d'expliquer olivier sur la casse du
service public
là on voi la problématique française les
contradictions sein de l'opinion
publique à la fois donc on va juger qu
on paie trop d'impôts trop de charges
sociales et puis l'autre côté on demande
en fait un service public extrêmement
donc présents qui assiste en permanence
la société française avec eux une
capacité à remettre en cause on va dire
des process donc issus du passé que ce
soit en matière de santé que ce soit au
niveau donc d'être des actions sociales
sur le terrain et donc c'est vrai qu'on
l'a on voit les blocages la société
française plus qu'un rapport on va dire
avec la civilisation sur l'aspect donc
des pme et sur la situation
donc des pme françaises des entreprises
françaises pouvoir que les troupes
françaises sont endettés c'est vrai mais
lent des rations qui sont assez
comparable à ce qu'on peut voir dans
d'autres pays européens que d'autres par
leur trésorerie a fortement augmenté
qu'elle arrive là depuis quelques mois à
améliorer leur taux de marge pour la
santé financière de l'entreprise est
moins dégradée que ce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre avec une telle crise
sanitaire
et si la reprise est aussi forte que
celle qu'on a connue au troisième
trimestre 2020 dans les prochaines
semaines
je pense que la situation va s'améliorer
pour un très grand nombre d'entreprises
françaises gelé
père et je suis assez confiant de mon
côté ci du crevale juste pour revenir
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure l'issue est
peut-on mettre fin sans facilement s est
un ordre interventionnisme comment on en
sort il est vrai que quand on a pris le
goût de l'argent facile de l'assistance
il est très difficile de revenir en
arrière surtout que en france on a des
élections de manière donc on est en
d'état électoral permanent
donc il ya une surenchère pour demander
le revenu universel pourquoi pas le
capital universel l'idée de doter les
jeunes d'un capital pour faciliter
l'accès dans la vie c'est assez légitime
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya des
inégalités patrimoniales deuxièmement le
logement coûte de plus en plus cher ce
qui est un vrai problème en france et et
c'est vrai qu'il va y avoir une pression
sur les ports publics en disant on
n'arrive pas à se loger décemment donc
il faut que l'état intervienne finance
donc la propriété encore de manière
beaucoup plus forte qu'aujourd'hui on
dépense déjà 37 milliards d'euros par an
pour le logement
donc oui et cette tentation va être va
perdurer et donc c'est évidemment la
capacité pour l'état les hommes
politiques les femmes politiques à ne
pas aller dans sur ce chemin glissant
car évidemment il ya olivier l'a dit à
demi-mot au bout du chemin il ya
forcément la banqueroute
il ya forcément donc l'état de faillite
et d'autre part aujourd'hui on tient
grâce quand même un effort plutôt à
l'accord de l'allemagne des pays bas et
de l'europe du nord qui consentent à ce
que la banque centrale européenne
finance autres économies le jour où ces
états qui sont un peu plus vertueux que
nous dit stop
évidemment là il ya un vrai problème
pour la france pour l'italie l'espagne
le portugal qui aujourd'hui vivent de la
monétisation de la dette pour financer
leurs dépenses courantes
olivier a même question alors moi je
veux juste revenir sur la casse la casse
sociale des services sociaux
mais c'est toujours la même chose le
problème c'est pas qu'il y a que les
français ne comprennent pas ou ne
veulent pas ni augmenter les impôts ni
avoir moins de services publics le
problème c'est aussi c'est juste une une
attribution c'est à dire que on paye le
plus d'impôts d'europe on perd en termes
de pourcentage du pib et on a des
services des services sociaux qu'on est
en train de casser
il ya quand même quelque chose qui va
pas ça veut dire qu'on dépense de
l'argent inutilement ailleurs et qu'on
pourrait peut-être remettre sur sur
l'hôpital ou remettre sur les les
services publics plutôt que de s'amuser
à chaque fois à réduire les les budgets
des services publics pour aller faire
des dvd des bêtises ailleurs et ne pas
vouloir changer le train de vie de
l'état pour pouvoir continuer dans
certains secteurs à abreuver d'argent
alors que c'est idiot et on sait à
entretenir des entreprises zombies extra
alors que ça coûte des dizaines de
milliards
tout ça pour prétexter de ça pour
pouvoir casser le service public c'est
idiot on pourrait très bien réaménager
les choses le budget est vrai à louer
sur des choses qui sont intéressantes
plutôt que d'aller dépenser son argent
n'importe comment ailleurs bon après sur
la croissance que vous semblez souhaité
en tout cas forte
malheureusement je crois que encore une
fois on va être déçu mais je je je
laisse le bénéfice du doute mais si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on tient et ça depuis
très longtemps déjà
depuis 2008 on ne tient que par la dette
c'est la dette qui est en train de
fouler la croissance or cette croissance
elle est inexistante sinon le potentiel
de croissance en france c'est un 1/2
peut-être bon donc on est loin du compte
et c'est pas avec 1,2 pour cent de
croissance que vous allez rembourser les
et rembourser les dettes à eni de faire
diminuer le chômage ni relancer quoi que
ce soit donc c'est une blague c'est
encore un espèce de 2,2 dessous et qui
malheureusement n'existera pas alors
qu'il ya un petit rebond
je n'en doute pas une demi-seconde sur
les chiffres vous avez déjà un effet de
base qui va faire que vous aurez un bon
mais derrière vous n'aurai absolument
pas de croissance parce qu'aujourd'hui
toute la croissance ne vient que de la
dette c'est à dire qu'on fait un déficit
budgétaire et on a en face un tout petit
peu de croissance mais sans effet de
levier
donc le problème il est là et si à
chaque fois vous des ses dépenses et 4
euros pour faire un euro de 2 de pub en
plus
excusez moi mais tout chef d'entreprise
sait que ça peut pas fonctionner
longtemps
merci merci beaucoup philippe crevel
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
directeur du cercle de l'epag olivier
les questions cash question à d'alex 78
olivier on entend parler à de déficit
tout le temps le pays at il déjà eu des
comptes dans le vert et comment y
parvenir à nouveau alors le oui on a eu
des comptes dans le vert mais c'était il
ya très très très très longtemps
ça ne l'est plus depuis depuis un bon
moment et ça l'est encore moins depuis
2008 où la l'état à jouer au bonneteau
avec la dette et a fait en sorte que la
dette privée bascule sur la sur la dette
publique donc vous avez ce phénomène là
qui s'est considérablement accéléré je
vous dis à partir de 2008 mais si vous
cherchez un budget positif
il y faut remonter à une cinquantaine
d'années donc on est on est loin du
compte
là la seule chose si vous voulez c'est
que vous pouvez vous pouvez avoir un
déficit c'est pas gênant d'avoir un
déficit
si vous avez de la croissance à mettre
en face si vous voulez si le fait de
dépenser 1 vous permet de créer 2
ou 3 et bien à ce moment là ça ne pose
aucun problème
mais le problème là aujourd'hui c'est
que vous dépensez trois ou quatre pour
faire 1 de croissance est là dans ce
sens là c'est plus possible très
longtemps donc si vous voulez
aujourd'hui on ne tient que par ça et
pas simplement en france c'est à peu
près dans tous les pays occidentaux aux
etats unis c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui on ne tient que parce que
l'état dépense de l'argent à tour de
bras
merci olivier maire c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine en attendant n'oubliez pas de
poser à toutes vos questions sur les
réseaux sociaux à olivier avec le
hashtag rt cash olivier sessa vous pour
le mot de la fin
via écouter l'état depuis déjà un bon
moment l'état se prend pour un moteur
alors que c'est un boulet